[Music]
if you are loyal followers of visual
politic you will have surely noticed
that there is a topic that we have
always been particularly fond of oil
well and Argentina as you already know
the fact is that crude oil continues to
have an enormous influence on
International politics that is why every
time large new deposits are discovered
it is exciting especially if they occur
in developing countries or in countries
that let's just say have not previously
been notable for their energy resources
that is often the preamble to many
political and also economic stories we
love it this was precisely the case of a
relatively unknown and sparsely
populated country that we have already
told you about several times here on
visual politic I'm of course talking
about Guyana the same Guyana that now
faces the challenge by bolivarian
Venezuela for the control of the esao
however this time we are not going to
tell you about Guyana but about its even
lesser known neighbor Surinam for many
the most prom promising country of
[Music]
2024 located between Guyana French Guana
and Brazil this country with around 90%
of its territory covered by the Amazon
rainforest is one of the smallest in
South America and also the least
populated it has only about 600,000
inhabitants Surinam which was first
cited by Christopher Columbus in 1498
and colonized by the Dutch from 1667
onwards is a country that is Ally gone
rather unnoticed let's just say that it
does not have a particularly important
geostrategic position it does not have a
developed economy nor does it have
resources of great significance or at
least that has been the case until now
you see just a few years ago Surinam
went from being a total unknown to being
in the Global Spotlight following this
news toal and Apache tout significant
oil find in Surinam Waters since then
the country has been in the sights of
both big oil companies and many major
world powers why because with the
discoveries made surin's bubbly Black
Gold could become one of the most
lucrative in the world right now the
industry hopes that Surinam can follow
in guyana's successful footsteps and
become a major supplier of crude oil
which given its small population could
make it an immensely wealthy country so
visual politic Community how has Surinam
come to this point why are so many hopes
being pinned on this small unknown
country could the conflict over esaka
Guyana disrupt its plans well you know
how it goes step on the gas and let's
get
started Surinam young and
turbulent since surin's creation as a
fully independent country in November
1975 this former Dutch Colony has not
had an easy history the country
situation as was also the case in
neighboring Guyana was devastating with
massive poverty and a very unproductive
underdeveloped Economy based almost
exclusively on Mineral exports the
situation was such that only 5 years
after its independence in 1980 what
typically happens in these cases also
occurred here a coupar took place and
with that someone who is surely the most
important figure in the political
history of this Young Nation came to
power Desi bhz head of the National
military Council after the catar boutz
promised the return of democracy by
1982 however with no sign of that
happening that very same year thousands
of demonstrators took to the streets and
confronted the military regime which
decided to execute 15 opposition
demonstrators following this all
financial aid from the Netherlands and
the United States was immediately
suspended dealing a death blow to the
Country surin's economy remained
severely stagnant for a long time social
and economic tensions reached such a
point that in 1985 boutz agreed to begin
the road to a return to democracy which
was completed in 1987 nevertheless the
ex dictator who must have missed being
in power staged another citar in 1990
however this second dictatorial period
lasted only a few months and in May 1991
elections were held again after pressure
from the United States and the
Netherlands since then democracy has
remained stable even so the same cannot
be said of its economy as you can see
everything started to change with the
new century starting in 2001 the
commodity super cycle began that is the
rise in commodity prices Surinam like
its South American neighbors benefited
greatly from this but the boom times
came to an end in 2015 and Surinam once
again collided with the harsh reality
mining its main economic activity was
not enough to get by yet that same year
news arrived that turned the hopes of
this forgotten country upside down Exxon
Mobile announces significant oil
Discovery offshore Guyana it had already
been known since the 18th century that
there were hydrocarbons in the Guyana
Surinam Basin but no significant amount
had ever been found as you can imagine
once the black gold gushed in Guyana the
next Target was going to be Surinam and
thus exploration soon began in 2016
Surinam was not a new country in terms
of oil exploration and exploitation it
started producing its first barrels as
early as 1982 in fact it has three
onshore Fields with reserves of about
1.1 billion barrels exploited by its
State Oil Company start so however those
fields and Wells would be left in the
dust after everything that began to be
discovered in 2020 listen
[Music]
up the oil
hope 2020 was a key year for Surinam and
not only because it had to deal with
covid-19 or because former dictator
boutz lost the elections after 10 years
in office 2020 was a key year for surar
because the first major oil fields were
finally found in its Waters oil Giants
Apache and total energies found the
first signs of large oil reserves they
have since found up to five fields in
Block 58 with estimated reserves of some
6.5 billion barrels of oil in these
fields alone crazy if we factor in that
the country has only 600,000 inhabitants
bear in mind that taking into account
the onshore field we're talking about
12,500 barrels of crude oil reserves per
capita we are there therefore talking
about potential profits of more than
$550,000 per capita and that's with most
of that amount going to the public cers
but that's not all the story is not over
yet other companies such as Chevron
shell and the Malaysian State Oil
Company petronus have also signed up to
this particular VIP party and are
exploring the various blocks in Surin
arm's Waters and guess what each of them
are hitting new and juicy
discoveries so as you can imagine in
Surinam they are thrilled about all this
they believe they will actually be able
to replicate guyana's economic miracle
for those of you who don't remember
Guyana has reported reserves of 11
billion Barrels in its offshore Fields
fields that have allowed it to be the
fastest growing economy since 2022 in
fact some analysts point out that by
2040 Guyana could raise as much as $60
billion an amount equivalent to $200,000
per capita in the next 17 years years
alone and that is without taking into
account other economic activity truly
outrageous however for the moment
Surinam does not have reserves estimated
to be as large as those declared by
Guyana but what it does have is a
president Chan santoki who is offering
conditions that no matter how you look
at it are too good to be
refused you see since the beginning of
his mandate and the first major
discoveries in Surinam Waters Sant has
focused on making the country an oasis
for oil investment for example instead
of offering 20-year production sharing
agreements as many of its South American
neighbors do it is offering them for 30
years which makes them better for
investment exploration and production
and not only that while royalties for
Oil Company revenues average around 16%
internationally sake is offering
royalties of only
6.25% only slightly higher than Guyana
and to top it off surin's offshore oil
is and sweet meaning it requires less
money to get good fuel well all these
conditions led the oil company Apache to
confirm in September 2023 that the
fields in Block 58 would be profitable
meaning that along with the French
company total energies they will invest
more than $9 billion to start production
in 2028 this is a real Boon for a
strongly depressed economy such as Surin
arms president santui has assured that
the money to be raised from the oil
contracts will go towards the much
needed diversification a of the economy
the existence of oil and gas is limited
so we have to use the revenues to
diverse the economy to invest in
agriculture in the tourism sector in
housing infrastructure for sustainable
development in the future in other words
oil May signal the end of the economic
model that has dominated Surinam since
it was a
[Music]
colony not surprisingly Sant also seeks
to address other problems such as the
impoverished conditions in which most of
the country's population lives or The
Chronic fiscal deficit that has led the
government to be mired in debt and its
currency to be significantly devalued in
recent years for the time being Sant has
already managed with oil projections in
hand to renegotiate surin's debt with
some of its creditors surami merges from
default with us $660 million in oil
related debt but wait a moment before
you jump the gun because most analysts
are warning of two major threats that
could Scupper the great aspirations of
the inhabitants of this small and
impoverished country who are now so
excited about all their bubbly Black
Gold pay close
[Music]
attention the Surinam
parasite like what has been happening in
prosperous Guyana a shadow also lurks in
Surinam the shadow of corruption as is
the case in many other countries of the
American continent Surinam is an
eminently corrupt country yes it is true
it has some laws to fight against fraud
money laundering and smuggling however
all those efforts have been useless
purely and simply because the most
important political figure in the
country has profited from all kinds of
illicit businesses we are talking of
course about the former dictator and now
former president B who has more plots in
his credit than an HBO series there is
no doubt at all analysts agree that
boutz turned Surinam into his own
private estate he even used all the
power of the state to profit from his
business in some cases links to to
International organized
[Music]
crime you see after the fall of his
second military government in 1991 boutz
began to build his own criminal Empire I
am talking about what is known as the
Suri cartel which focuses on arms and
narcotics trafficking in fact in 1999 he
was sentenced to 16 years in prison in
the Netherlands for drug trafficking
offenses and for the murder of 15
civilians in 1982 boutz is so wanted
that as of today he cannot leave Surinam
because he has an International arrest
warrant issued by eurol but he is not
the only one who has been tried for
these crimes his eldest son Dino boutz
was even apprehended and convicted in
2015 for nothing short of the following
I think you'll be surprised check it out
suram Leader's son gets 16 years us
prison for Hezbollah Aid in general Desi
boutz was able to take advantage of the
favorable conditions for illicit
businesses that Surinam offers keep in
mind that being 90% covered by the dense
Amazon rainforest this country is a
great hiding place for organized crime
what's more its population is small and
there are hardly any police forces to
control the borders of this vast region
making the trafficking of weapons drugs
and other Goods relatively easy and
that's not all during the last 40 years
bout's corruption has seeped into the
rest of the layers of the state the
result these days in Surinam clientelism
and bribes to officials are a daily
occurrence in fact one of the main
reasons why massive protests erupted in
early 2023 was precisely this massive
corruption that is why most analysts as
well as the country's own citizens fear
that the oil money will end up mostly in
the hands of corrupt politicians and
officials true president sake is trying
to strengthen the fight against
corruption but the reality is that after
40 Years of parasitizing the state boutz
has made the task particularly
hard and keep in mind this is not the
only threat to the country's future
revenues or even future oil plans
several analysts point to another threat
that has to do with the conflict over
Guyana esaka chavismo wins referendum
for the annexation of the eso and raises
tension with Guyana Venezuela
intensifies the conflict with Guyana
over the esao and gives an ultimatum to
Exxon and other oil producers the esao
conflict has shattered the relatively
geopolitical stability enjoyed by the
territory bear in mind that if Venezuela
fulfills its promise and annexes the
territory Guyana would lose 74% of its
current territory and let's see it seems
unlikely to happen but what can I say
with crazy and greedy dictators you
never know in any case the risks need to
be taken into account well it must be
taken into account that although most of
the Welles that have given Wings to
guyana's economy are not in the
territorial waters of Equatorial Guinea
if the latter were to fall into the
hands of Venezuela Guyana would lose
important oil fields in total it would
lose three of its eight current oil
fields and half of the largest and most
fruitful so far the stab broke field
that is why visual politic viewers there
are those who are wondering if Venezuela
were to ultimately take the es aibo
would it be possible that Guyana would
start to claim or even try to take
surin's territories to compensate for
its losses in theory everything points
to
no the maritime territorial disputes in
oil Rich Waters between Guyana and
Surinam were already set in 2007 in fact
the international arbitration gave a
much more favorable result to Guyana
than to Surinam as a result Guyana could
not claim Waters from Surinam and what
about land territory yes it is true both
countries have a territorial dispute
over a region south of both countries
the Tigre region however the reality is
that Guyana has controlled this
territory with its troops since it
breached the agreement with Surinam to
withdraw them in 1971 therefore Guyana
would have no legitimate claim to either
the waters or any of Surin arm's lands
in fact the reality is that right now it
would not be in its interest to go up
against Surinam following this news
Surinam supports Guyana in its conflict
with Venezuela despite bilateral border
issue however what could happen is that
the drums of war in the region could be
put on hold and that could slow down
many Investments which may delay the oil
dreams of a country that could become
one of the most promising in the world
as early as 2024 so you see everything
points to the next economic Miracle
staying in the ganas but this time in
Surinam the former Dutch Colony has a
golden opportunity ahead of it it
certainly has time to prepare and try to
correct many of its major problems after
all the first barrels from the new
Fields will not start gushing until 2028
but at this point the questions are now
over to you do you think Surinam will be
able to replicate the success of
neighboring Guyana what do you think
they should do in the face of widespread
corruption is it possible for Big Oil to
avoid conflict in es aibo and in the
region you can leave us your answers in
the comments as always don't forget that
here on visual politic we release new
videos every week so subscribe to the
channel and hit the little bell icon so
you don't miss any updates if you like
this video like it and I'll see you in
the next one all the best see you
[Music]
soon